une deux questions enfin c'est plutôt
des romains sont pas uniquement des
questions qui sera assis fondamentale la
première c'est de dire on a besoin de
souplesse dans la gestion de la fonction
publique territoriale
je suivais dit fabienne qui est dans la
sarthe je suis maire d'une commune
rurale j'ai besoin de gérer au fond mais
mes employés municipaux
aujourd'hui c'est pas possible vous le
savez bien il ya des mères dans la salle
c'est extrêmement compliqué de
réellement gérer c'est à dire décider de
la rémunération de l'avancement
éventuellement des sanctions des
promotions c'est extrêmement compliqué
il faut qu'on renverse les choses dans
ce dans ce domaine qui est qui au fond
et essayer c'est nécessaire c'est
nécessaire pour les fonctionnaires les
fonctionnaires eux mêmes le chante on le
voit bien les fonctionnaires ils veulent
quoi ils veulent à la fois évidemment
d'être assurés d'une certaine sécurité
de leurs travailleurs ne pas être soumis
aux aléas politiques on peut les
comprendre
et quand on est fonctionnaire
territorial voilà les maires changent
mais les fonctionnaires doivent pouvoir
rester et ne pas être entraîné par les
vicissitudes de la vie politique sans le
comprend bien
mais un deuxième point qui est
évidemment les fonctionnaires il doit
pouvoir dans des carrières qu'ils soient
rémunérés ou dont l'avancement soit
déterminé par leurs propres mérites
pines sont tout à fait naturel et il n'y
a pas de raison que ce soit si différent
dans le privé dans le public donc on
travaillera sur l'idée de quels contrats
comment gérer la relation entre
l'employeur et l'employé entre l'état la
collectivité territoriale et puis le
fonctionnaire
quelle évolution du statut de la
fonction publique il faut noter tout à
l'heure nathalie disait à juste titre
que iliad et des métiers qui sont
réalisés dans le privé qui sont réalisés
dans le public sont exactement les mêmes
métiers ils doivent pouvoir est
également être traités de la même façon
il n'ya pas de paille wardin équité
entre les français et les fonctionnaires
ils doivent avoir beaucoup d'avenir dans
la fonction publique beaucoup d'avenir
quel que soit leur statut et et
notamment pouvoir être rémunéré de
meilleures façons quand on voit les
enseignants aujourd'hui ils sont souvent
pas suffisamment rémunérés
il enseigne à qui est-ce qui a pu plus
cher pour pour douce et à nos propres
enfants
on essaie de d'entraîner nos enfants
vers le meilleur
on y croit et en même temps on soupèse
la plupart des enseignants ya là un
véritable problème
alors il doit y avoir du donnant donnant
sur le temps de travail sur le statut
sur les risques que l'on doit pouvoir
prendre lorsqu'on travaille également
dans le public tous ces sujets on va les
aborder
ils dépendent aussi de la réforme qu'on
est capable de mener avec notre propre
état et propres structures publiques nos
structures publiques elles sont rigides
le monde il est il est souple et un
moment donné l'un des deux va cacher
trouver lequel c'est évidemment celui
qui s'ouvre la plus grande rigidité
on doit pouvoir s'adapter au monde qui
vient tout à l'heure stéphane à parler
d'innovation il est chef d'entreprise il
a parlé du numérique le numérique c'est
un début il ya des quelques milliards de
gens qui sont aujourd'hui connectés à
peu près un tiers de la planète donc on
voit bien que on a besoin est de plus en
plus numérique
il gouvernera le monde alors il a
instillé dans tous les pans de
l'économie
il n'y a pas une économie nouvelle et
une économie ancien ue une économie qui
va être au fur et à mesure du temps
totalement transformé par des
applications du numérique et numérique
c'est quoi c'est de mettre tout le monde
en relation
c'est d'être très très rapide c'est de
faire en sorte que des gens qui se
parlaient pas et peuvent se parler
ils peuvent se trouver et ils peuvent
conclure ensemble un certain nombre de
choses dans la vie privée comme dans la
vie publique dans la vie des affaires et
si on doit en tenir compte de plus en
plus ça veut dire aussi qu'il faut
répond un certain nombre de questions
quel est le le dur et de la durée de la
transition la transition numérique elle
affecte un certain nombre de professions
on le voit aujourd'hui ce qui se passe
sur les taxis ou sur les vtc ce qui se
passe pour les hôteliers ce qui se passe
dans beaucoup de professions c'est une
transformation de leur profession et
l'état y doit assurer l'égalité des uns
et des autres on a beau travailler dans
le domaine du numérique ont produit de
la valeur
et si on produit de la valeur il doit y
avoir la fiscalité alors on peut
réformer le système fiscal c'est un
autre sujet il faut pas transformer pour
les numériques faut le transformer pour
que chacun doive payer à la nation ce
qu'il doit à la nation et doit pas y
avoir ce qu'ils payent pas d'impôts et
ce qui est évidemment paye tous les
impôts s'est tellement tellement évident
et puis aussi la relation du travail
quel contrat de travail ce contrat il
doit évoluer le contrat il était fait
pour les personnes qui rentrent dans l'
usine à 7h du matin et en ressorte le
choix le contrat travail ils doivent
s'adapter à la société du numérique est
tout simplement une société plus souple
et puis dernier point il ya tout le
problème de la liberté
le numérique c'est des bases de données
c'est d'énormes bases de données c'est
énorme de base de données elle pose la
question de la liberté liberté des uns
et des autres le respect de la vie
personnelle et de la vie privée et en
même temps pour mieux vivre on a besoin
du numérique et ses bases de données
c'est des sujets qui les socialistes ont
tenté traitée dans le cadre d'une loi le
numérique mais n'y ont pas apporté de
réponse donc on va y aller on va
expliquer comment créer tout ça on va
expliquer qu'aujourd'hui il ya quelques
années les jeunes il voulait aller dans
des grandes entreprises aujourd'hui
veulent créer leur start up
ça veut dire qu'on croit en la réalité
des projets et informe en affirmant
absolument formidable pour l'avenir de
notre pays
et évidemment les républicains sont au
coeur de cela